who were the philosophers and
philosophical ideas that influenced you
the most are we just jumping right in
that's we're right and we're not
interested no foreplay
on camera all right i had an interesting
philosophical journey at least i think
it's interesting
and that was i think
as far as organized philosophy or maybe
uh
i think authentic's not the right word
but like uh
yeah we'll stay organized um
i would say that nietzsche is probably
one of the people with the most
influence on on me
but i also feel like to a degree
your personality and will oftentimes
dictate what philosophers that you can
you can vibe with
yeah so what what ideas from nietzsche
was it the the ubermaj
definitely the ubermensches is huge to
me because i see it as an extension
of basically the religious concepts of
god
and higher ideals but just put into a
different a secular context
and the idea also that the ubermensch
is a striving and overcoming you know
something that you're always working
towards
that very few will ever it's not like
the the concept that you can just
make them it doesn't happen that way and
it's not based simply upon
if you were say put through a genetic
program and
and and turned into a super soldier like
i wouldn't that wouldn't make it
you know that's like the the the very
surface level and incorrect
understanding what ubermensch is
the ubermensch is the idea of this this
kind of
human that that transcends all the
the weaker lower aspects of humans which
we're full of
but i also think that there's an element
in nietzsche's writing that suggests
that it's not something
you can't even be in all the time like
it's
even a temporary state because it's not
something that we're capable of
maintaining
it's something to strive for like a
morality
uh an image ideal a set of principles
that we can connect to
that doesn't rely on otherworldly
kind of uh outdoor things
with nietzsche i feel like the concept
of the ubermensch um
is something built on authenticity as
well
as heidegger was like dozen right so
when you are authentic
and heidegger being a follower of
nietzsche's
and highly influenced by him uh with i
think that the ubermensch is an example
of authenticity in that it isn't about
trying to be anything that you cannot be
or
to go against who you are but to
actually
understand that accept that and then
work with what you can work with and
and and create from your
lump of clay that is you because i can't
become certain there's certain things
that are just not going to happen for me
because it's not in my proclivity i mean
i'm never gonna be
you know five foot tall and 120 pounds i
mean that
again i guess but uh
um but i know but
as you get more in tune with who you are
as you start learning more about
what unique things or at least what that
that combination that makes you that
gestalt part of yourself
what those things are and how you can
use them then you know you can work
towards being
that all taking what that is and seeing
if you can
get to that point now the likelihood is
no maybe probably never i mean but we
can never achieve godhood yet
religion is is a constant you know
striving and a look at
a higher ideal concept even if it's
multiple gods or one god it's
still essentially all built around this
concept like i i like the idea of
uh catholics original sin if you think
of sin not as evil but as
you know missing the mark the archer's
term where it derives or even like in
spanish you know without so as being
if you accept that you are imperfect if
you accept that you you need to
constantly strive even against yourself
because you you will figure out the best
ways at which to
submarine your own capabilities
submarine your own
dreams and wishes and whatever you will
ruin them more than anything else
and you will tell yourself that you
ruined them on purpose for a good reason
or you'll say that
you'll figure out a way to put it on
everything else but yourself
and so the idea of thinking of
well as i'm starting off on this whole
thing i got a lot of work to do and
that's just the way it is and i got to
figure out what areas those are going to
be
and so you know i thought oh yeah if i
think of original sin
actually can be that can be kind of a
clever idea but it's also
just accepting that we're all
uniquely strange and unequal in our own
ways
but we have to figure out how that fits
in the word uh authenticity kind of
connects to all of that so
striving to be your authentic self means
figuring out exactly the shape of the
flaws
the the character of your like little
demons that you get to play with and
around them finding a path to whatever
the hell uh
ideal versions of yourself you can carve
and pretending like that's
such a thing is even possible
you